>>David Upchurch: Mangahigh is
an online educational resource.
>>Toby Rowland: Over the last
three years, we have learned
that there's some rules
for math game creation.
>>One rule was that the game
mechanic had to be the map.
>>Chris Green: The concept that
we now have launched has gone
through many phases to make
it exciting and challenging
and to make the gradient, the
slope, of learning just right.
What's key is that you're constantly
having to solve mathematics problems,
but you're doing it in such
a way that it's exciting,
it's challenging, it's engaging.
>> David Upchurch: All our
games are built around an API
that queries the game constantly
about how the student's doing
and how they're performing, where
they're struggling and so forth.
That's all fed back
to us here and some
of that data's also made available
to teachers via their admins.
>> Toby Rowland: The games through
the APIs are embedded in the site.
That means that teachers can set
tasks within games for students
and they can be sure that their
students are going to go directly
into that level of the game
and immediately be on task.
>>Chris Green: Students have to
be out of their comfort zones.
If you're in your comfort zone and
you're getting things right and right
and right and teaches tiny
increments in difficulty or just more
of the same, what have you learned?
You've really learned nothing.
That's not something that
students are necessarily used to
and it's quite scary for teachers as
well to have the idea that, you know,
we want students to make mistakes.
We want them to learn
from those mistakes.
We want them to be
uncomfortable in a math classroom.
We don't want kids just sitting
there churning stuff out.
We want them to feel
that there's a sense
that I might not achieve
everything today.
That is where the real
learning goes on
and that's a challenge
creating Mangahigh Resources.
That's what we want to create.